okay so as the Anime Cafe expert now
sure you've been to more than like all
of us combined I've I've missed you
around 27. okay yeah definitely okay
what is what has been like your best
experience
your Cafe I went with family on that it
was actually amazing it was actually I
got the dog [__] one you told me to the
terrible one which Banana Fish yeah you
liked the pasta the pasta yeah the pasta
was okay but it was just all [__] oh I
mean yeah yeah they charged like like a
[__] thirty dollars a cookie yeah but
that's Anime Cafe yeah it was like they
barely themed it they put up a bunch of
wallpaper on colder today oh yeah and I
got a reserve you're gonna reserve for
this
[__] off dude that's what pisses me off
is that I have to reserve to go to
something that's mid and I'm like no no
don't no no you don't get to remember no
you'll go for like
the Instagram moment you know no that's
kind of all it's for in the room if
you're a true fan
I am gonna if I if I swear to God if I
have to buy clear files I'm I'm not oh
no no no no no no no that's an immediate
skills
I'm sorry I mean that had plates and
cups and stuff like that yeah I'll take
you to better ones maybe okay okay let's
go to a better one next time it was so
cute because like the merch they
actually like put effort into it so it's
just good yeah no it did what I maybe
I've been it it gave me what I've been
wanting from an anime collab Cafe where
right every menu item you could look at
it and you could pinpoint exactly what
they're referencing yeah from the manga
or the show yeah like it's I was like oh
that's the Siever you go drop some Curry
yeah that's the scene with the meals
hair cubes that's the scene with like
you could yeah it was really
an episode where like uh Yuko asked for
yaksoba and then they get the order but
it's yakisaba which is like the fried
fish right so I ordered the yaksoba and
she was like okay so who ordered the yak
soba and I was like I did and they
brought out this like [__] plastic
container like this white plastic
container and I opened it up and it was
a fried fish
and then five minutes later she came
back with the actual
like that's brilliant that's [__]
five head man I trolled at the [__]
Cafe but it's like it's actually unique
and like fun and imagine someone hadn't
seen nichijo and they were like uh wrong
excuse me excuse me I thought it was
troll when I gave us the food in our
Cafe I was like
okay
premium experience not the premium
experience have you been to a dojo Cafe
uh
that's tight that's that's high yeah
it's probably it's probably why it's
good yeah bro yeah oh yeah well um
they're only uh fake cafes coming out
hear me up I'm surprisingly knocked bro
free fans don't leave the house what do
you mean
fate Fender stop playing at the time
they would have to log off and go in
real life like we'd lose money
all you need to do is be like be just
like Pokemon go it you know like oh you
come to this one physical Place yeah one
free pool yo there's a line that
stretches from like here to Kyoto man
like [__] it up I'll let you know if I
see a face all right okay so you've
talked about cafes thank you like yeah
what is one thing that maybe you know
you kind of hated about Japan after the
fact you became to dislike a lot so it's
not necessarily like something I dislike
about Japan it's just there's now I uh
after moving here and like making
content here
I have now exposed to a new genre of
annoying ass YouTube comments
I feel like you guys have talked about
this already but now that I have to deal
with it I'm going to complain about it
yeah okay so you have two two sides of
the spectrum all right yeah on one side
you have the Japan dick riders yeah who
get really mad at you if you dare say
anything even a little bit negative yeah
oh that's all I ever [__] do yeah oh
it's like fresh taste go ahead so just
like in one of my what is it like they
it's so annoying and one of my themed
Cafe videos I got a comment there was
actually a few that were like this that
were like typical Western girl uh hates
that Japan won't cater to to her taste
buds because I said that the burgers
that they or on Cafe were [__] yeah yeah
that's a troll issue they were just bad
food like it's the type of commenter who
is like
how dare you like say anything they
assume that like whatever you eat in
Japan it is god-like yeah yeah they they
treat Japan as like a Utopia they can't
do wrong right yeah
some good burger joints but yeah yeah
and then on the uh similarly on the
other annoying side of the spectrum you
have the Japan haters yeah who no matter
what you say like if you say anything
even a little positive they they have to
come in and like rain on your parade
yeah like they'll be like hey I went
they and I had a really good time and
then someone will come and be like have
fun getting sexually assaulted on the
train yeah dude
it's always the most like they they
clearly like can't take the particular
situation you're in and yeah negative
about that situation so they have to
bring some kind of wild tangent right
like you could be doing like oh here I
am at a at a 7-Eleven let's try all the
sandwiches and then one of the comments
would be like yeah but do you know what
the Japanese did during World War II was
that absolutely horrible and I'm like
what does that have to do with anything
Jerry's grandma just told about it yeah
I've got a first-hand account yeah
exactly it's like it's like I can't
obviously like you can't please
everybody of course I mean there's
there's been so much Japan praise online
for a very very long time there's a lot
of pushback to it and it makes us weird
and then there's people who are very
protective of it like you said it's just
a whole weird thing it's very weird when
it's very fun to hear Japanese is people
I went to the bar uh like two nights ago
um and uh the guy asked us to move up
because more customers coming because
it's small right yeah move up and then
there's a Japanese guy and there's two
of them they're absolutely smashed and
he goes he tries to grab my hand I'm
like all right and he was like you like
Japan I was like yeah Japan's pretty
good uh he starts going off about
how he feels about Japan right Japanese
guy
he goes everyone in Japan is hentai and
I was like all right he's like everyone
is hentai and I was like all right okay
he gets this guy right here pointing at
the bar guy this guy's biggest hentai I
know it's just a normal bar working guys
don't know each other I was like all
right all right he kept saying it louder
and louder this guy right here this guy
this particular guy is a pervert the
biggest pervert in Japan and he keeps
going off I'm just like I'm like that
all right okay dude all right all right
so the Batman comes over like hey could
you please shut the [__] up that's all
the customers please [__] stop and
he's like no you're a [__] answer
you're like please please please stop
and his friends like dude dude I was
like chill
what the [__] Jesus uh yeah that was uh
that was my fun experience
yeah I love this place and he was
telling me he's an architect and I was
like what do you think about Japanese
Architects she goes Super [__]
it's like we build and tear down right
away I mean that is true yeah he's like
you know he's like Europe is the gold
standard of architecture I was like oh
cool I was like can't wait to tell God
and Joey then
[__] them no they were they were funny
guys they were great yeah uh but they
were with like a girl who looked
extremely young oh oh yeah they were
like yeah they were like in their 40s
they're like yeah it's a 20 year old
girl with them all right cool t-shirt
that's not why they were shouting in the
previous state by now
at least he's self-aware it was a fun
night though yeah